we've got Lapita nyongo here hello it's
so good to see you it's been a long time
since we've seen Nakia can you tell us a
little bit what she's been up to
find out that's fair well maybe just
catch some of you what's like not there
like okay she went to the beach or
something she did go to the beach the
beach is great
yeah I mean you know it's been a while
since we last saw her she's grown and
you know matured she's also lost her
main love so we see how she's handling
that yes now Nakia is a war dog and I
know for a lot of people they often
assume that she's a dorm Elijah tell us
a little bit about adore Malaysia tell
us a little bit of the difference
between war dogs and dorm Elijah for
people who are not in the know well war
dogs are undercover spies so they're
training yes they're trained and and
combat and stuff like that but their
training is very different they go under
the radar whereas the Dora milaje are
very much
um the army of of wakanda so they
definitely have to work in tandem but
she's a little bit more exposed to the
rest of the world and she's like she's
the one who brings Intel to wakanda that
keeps them on top I want to dive in
deeper about I'm so fascinated about
your you know experience as being at
this war dog Nakia you know she spends a
lot of her time away from wakanda but
she loves it keeps her going in her
mission
wow
that I need to pass
what what keeps her going I think love
of country and love of a love of her
people and uh she is a very principal
person there's certain things she stands
for and she really believes in the power
of humanity together and I think she
brings that to her work I mean a plus
right there I mean he just doesn't pass
the fast right there Lavina I know
there's so many people who want to get
to talk to we're so excited to see you
back here in the uncu and taking us
through wakanda forever so thank you so
much anything you want to say to the
Marvel fans before we head out I'm just
so happy to be back
we love you so much enjoy the night
Lupita so good to see you